hello everyone i'm alan and welcome to
my channel where today i am watching the
gamescom opening night live i didn't get
a chance to
actually watch it live so i'm basically
right now i'm gonna jump over like all
of the biggest announcements
this video is going to suck to edit
before we jump into that i do have to
let you know this video is sponsored by
epic games and we will hear more from
them shortly but for now
let's just jump into it who is this man
and why is this starting with him
and why is it so jumpy
if i didn't have games i think i
guess i would just be writing a lot more
it's me that is what i always say
i need to figure out what's going on
with the audio it's skipping for some
reason it's so
weird all right so we're just gonna do
this whole thing differently because the
stream wasn't gonna work and it was
complicated
so here are the 11 biggest trailers and
announcements from gamecock
i'm sorry what i'm sorry what
what um what is this you know six years
ago we were on this
what did somebody say dragon age teen
game awards
accepting the game of the year for
dragon age inquisition
and since then we've been imagining new
ways to use next generation technology
to bring the world and characters of
dragon age to life it's time to give you
the very first look
at how bioware's passionate team of
developers are crafting this very
special game
i didn't expect this to happen today
it's probably not going to be footage
they're right it's just going to be like
well that's not end game i've been a bio
okay well that's just a real man
we're always trying to improve innovate
and bring new characters this isn't
going to be anything
to enjoy very well
the world of dragon age really has got
it all
it's a fantastic opportunity
every time
hey nice concept dog didn't tell me much
happy to hear about dragon age that's
great
and now for the sponsored part of this
video thanks to epic games for
sponsoring this video
if you guys didn't already know season 4
nexus war just released
in fortnight so now is the perfect time
to jump in
if you haven't downloaded fortnite
already use my link in the description
below to download fortnite
for free oh it's honestly very wild
watching this collaboration
there is something incredibly cool
about all of these characters coming to
fortnite
uh i don't know why i didn't see it
coming but
that's dumb the new season which is
technically
chapter two season four is dubbed nexus
one and it's a comic book style event
which is what
actually got me very interested in this
where major characters team up to fight
off one of my
favorite marvel villains ever galactus
and galactus is such a cool villain to
fight and so big
just just a very cool idea for sure
those who get fortnight's season battle
pass will be able to unlock the likes of
iron man
storm mystique dr doom another one of my
favorite villains groot
and she-hulk along with the amnesiac
thor so yeah the whole thing is about
teaming up with marvel's greatest heroes
and villains it should be
very fun to watch huge thanks to epic
sponsoring this video
uh check out the link in my description
below and back to gamescom
fall guys is getting a second season we
can do like a quick little watch this
hey i'm joe i'm the lead game designer
on full guys ultimate knockout and i
just wanted to reach out and say thank
you to everyone who's been playing and
enjoying the game so far
there's a team we've been looking at all
the fan arts the memes and the montages
been posting online and the response of
the game has really blown us away
today we just wanted to give everyone
their first sneak peek at the rounds and
the costumes that they can be enjoying
as part of four guys season two
[Music]
if i see a single tail i swear to god
[Applause]
dragons the dragon's really cute
it's like a little fantasy season two
you'll be dressing your full guy as a
medieval hero
and competing across brand new rounds
inspired by epic quests from the middle
ages cute
neat into it what else a better look at
star wars i do want to watch this one
light
or dark freedom or destruction
this comes out to destroy alderaan in
order to spread fear
and douse the fires of rebellion but the
heroic pilots of the rebel alliance
have chosen to keep fighting to show the
empire that we are not
afraid it was their bravery that ended
palpatine's reign
and brought about our new republican
cinematic however
the empire lives on shattered though it
may be
as i speak imperial forces are edging
toward the bormier sector
hoping to end our new republic before we
find off i don't know what
else i need to see from this game i was
really happy with the gameplay we
already saw
it's gorgeous but the galaxy is changing
and you can be a part of it
i love a solid brave and daring pilots
this war can
end make a choice fly with the new
republic
i'm definitely injured galaxy for the
better
hi i'm suzanne hunka narrative producer
on star wars squadrons
over the course of the story you'll fly
as two pilots on
opposite sides of the war and like all
modes in star wars squadrons
you'll have the option to experience
every mission fully immersed in vr
rogue squadron i hear you're the reason
i was able to finally get stuff
today you'd probably make me think about
an early imperial mission
behind enemy lines one of our spies
agent thorne has discovered vital
intelligence on project starhawk
your mission is to extract her from an
orbital outpost above hosni and prime
behind enemy lines you'll have to
eliminate perimeter defenses
the outpost is defenseless when you've
secured the area
you will escort the gladius to the
outpost and our construction team will
acquire it emotives games just look
gorgeous once thorn is secure
reach your gozanti cruises and return to
the overseer
cover our escape and escort us to the
jump point we have republic corvettes
inbound
like there's no doubt this game
looks incredible all right take out
those fighters
understood i'll handle it
[Music]
you have my thanks titan squadron no
time to celebrate
very cool each mission will immerse you
into the escalating concept this is a
huge
republic and a shattered empire debrief
with your squad mates between
i missions if there's like a hub that
you can actually walk around the
galaxy's finest
or is it all focused and ready i don't
know that much about it
from bombing runs at the nadiri
dockyards
to setting a trap in the xavian abyss
the story of these rival squadrons will
push the war to the brink
and define the galaxy yeah i'm
definitely going to play with some vr i
see how
much my stomach can handle i get per
second pretty evil sick but
hell yeah continues to look awesome
on board okay what else have we got
12 minutes aha i remember this one being
shown at uh
at uh e3 i believe
it's annapurna yeah there it is
i want you to think of a flower
look at its contours its curves
now i want you to imagine it changing
i'm very interested in what this game is
think of that bud
unopened look at it as a whole
and silently repeat these phrases
may you be free from suffering oh my god
what may you be
free from fear may you know
peace that just made me sad
[Music]
wow
[Music]
william defoe was that him that's crazy
annapurna just published so many good
unique cool games oh ratchet and plank
okay
for real from a technical perspective
ratchet and clank rift-a-pot is the game
i am the most excited about
for next-gen i think this game looks
incredible i love insomniac
and i very much want to see more of this
it's so weird to be this excited about
russian clank
um not that it's you know not a beloved
franchise but i'm like
this is the one this is it this is
next-gen
it's not it's forza you know
okay i was gonna say that can't be
actual gameplay surely actual gameplay
doesn't look that good
we're back and not far from where we
last
saw him we may still have time to put a
stop to this
this looks really detailed oh dear
okay no it does look really good this
gameplay
does look just as good as the cinematics
weapons always going to be awesome
scratching the plank it's insomniac
never had any doubt with any of that
it feels good to be back in action
last one
the train's pulling away let's go
the city looks massive too
hard to say though could be super linear
physics all right
i'm telling you you're all sleeping on
ratchet and playing i'm looking
everywhere for you
put down the dimensionator nefarious
[Music]
all right boss
it's a very interesting choice for his
voice it sounds like an elderly man with
like kind of a call
he's kind of reminding me of general
grievous
hitting nefarious device seems to have
destabilized reality
love that for us there has to be another
way across
hmm the ritz appeared to react to your
device
try pointing it at one of them i'm so
excited to see how this works
[Music]
it also just looks beautiful like the
physics are great
i just feel like so many people watching
this are going to be like i don't
understand why she's so hyped about this
but i keep wanting to be like you don't
understand the tech
that's so cool or at least a very large
octopus
i would to be fair get very overwhelmed
if this game was consistently this
action-packed though like you're gonna
need to chill out on me a little bit
used to that
did dr nefarious really resurface after
all these
i also just feel like versus the lost
ratchet like these
lighting effects for these weapons
he must have more planned than he is
that looks beautiful
there's a lot going on on screen with no
lag too
damn
that was cool
what is this place
that was cool i would like to go back
there
[Music]
i'm getting like massive star wars vibes
from this
is that because we just watched the
squadron trailer i don't know but all of
this is very star wars
and is this all gameplay or
i think it is this is very star wars
come on
like how scripted of these bits
they separated wretched oh no
ratchet ratchet too late
someone needs to mix that into it like
an adm mix
ratchet that's right it's girl [ __ ]
great loved it game of show beautiful
playstation 5 exclusive
incredible yes please that was captioned
on ps5 too i love that they specify that
our virtual reality take a medal of
honor isn't necessarily the most
exciting proposition i'm totally
covering this up i'm sorry
but this version is held by respawn oh
now you have my attention
i have an oculus rift i love my oculus
rift i use it on
a daily basis you got me based on it
being respawned
let's go
i know this is the first time so it's
only on oculus
oh this is literally from the oculus
channel yeah this might be an oculus
exclusive to be clear with all of you
i'm scared too it's got to be hard to do
an oculus trailer
wow
i feel like it's happening like after
alex
i definitely trust graceful resistance
like we're getting
people fighting full story experiences
on on but you really should stop
oculus there is no future
sorry to interrupt lieutenant
[Music]
all right all right
it's a hard sell on this because it's
really just a matter of what does it
feel like to play in the vr
it's i just can't even imagine being a
marketing team oculus like how hard that
is to do you know
looks cool though i'm yeah i am sold i
am going to play it i want to check it
out
that's neat somehow this motley crew has
been tasked with saving civilization
respawn are fantastic they've been just
back-to-back bangers lately
okay what else we got doom eternal
expansion
this is called the ancient gods we have
been analyzed for some time now
i'm down to play morrow dummy tunnel i
enjoyed my time with that game a lot i
really
smashed through it i'll take them all
the swimming mechanics were kind of
brutal though
sometimes very hard to surface so that's
not a great selling point
slayer has arrived yeah
that's my ideal pawn
screwing up one of those emo boys in his
stupid face
with a ballista and a super shotgun
certainly looks like doom
yeah we like it we like it
oh that's just so rude
that was like the end of doom a tunnel
there's a part where there's like
[ __ ] three of them at once it's just
the meanest thing ever i
i hate the i hate them i still hate
whiplashes more though you know
so hopefully the voge didn't let me down
that's everything that they have listed
uh obviously a couple that i passed on
watching for for brevity's sake
i mean i didn't watch the call of duty
trailer because call of duty trailers
gonna be a call of duty trailer and
always gonna feel the same about them
which is
looks fantastic great sound design
this is a this is very cool for the sims
community for sure that's really neat
uh great use of that license because i
feel like ea is like not made anywhere
near as many star wars games or
crossovers as they should have in the
amount of time they've had that license
but
and yeah a little dragon age reveal
pretty neat stuff
so hopefully that's also a handy
synopsis for you guys if there was
anything anyone saw in the show that uh
i missed here that you'd really like to
see this is obviously just from opening
night live not from the rest of gamescom
please let me know i'd love to check it
out alright i'll see you guys next time
bye